disparition tragique et actes
terroristes
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur a rencontré ce matin les
policiers du commissariat des mureaux
c'est ici que travailler le commandant
de police tué hier soir avec son épouse
secrétaire au commissariat de mantes la
jolie par un homme se revendiquant de
l'état islamique
j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer aux
policiers notre immense tristesse
toute notre compassion dans le de leur
dire la solidarité de la république dans
toutes ses forces se rassembler ce qui
nous importe
à nous tous
au sein de l'appareil d'état à la fois
la chancellerie et au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est que nous puissions
faire avancer cette enquête de manière à
mettre hors d'état de nuire d'éventuels
complices
tout est à la fois seule touche choquer
pour choquer bien évidemment s'ils sont
plus choqués encore connue
est-ce que c'est comme le reconnaît
sur cette institution au registre de la
polyvalence et
donc c'est vraiment ce que représente
notre république à magnanville commune
de 6000 habitants où étaient domiciliés
les victimes
le quartier résidentiel peine à
retrouver sa tranquillité
on les chope tout l'hélicoptère est
passé au dessus de ma maison donc ça
fait drôle et on habite juste derrière
donc on a vu le défilé de de police de
sapeurs compte et nous avons toute la
nuit des choqué par tout ça les
riverains déplacées par les forces de
l'ordre durant la nuit ont réintégré
leur logement la commune a mis en place
une cellule psychologique en lien avec
la préfecture ce matin avec ma première
adjointe et mon équipe municipale et
l'éducation nationale on a mis une
cellule de soutien psychologique auprès
des élèves et de neuf de leurs parents
donc dans les écoles de magnanville je
vais mettre aussi nos cellules de
soutien auprès du périscolaire de mon
personnel qui est très choquée parce que
le petit bonhomme
il avait aussi au périscolaire
l'agresseur l'art aussi à balla a été
tué lors de l'assaut du raid
trois personnes de son entourage sont en
garde à vue une minute de silence en
hommage aux deux fonctionnaires se fera
demain au commissariat des mureaux